j'essaie de sortir de mon pays
malheureusement c'est
euh je dois partir parce qu'il
n'y a aucun moyen pour moi et il n'y a pas
d'avenir pour moi et pour mon mari de rester
ici
[Musique]
donc
et maintenant  nous sommes à l'aéroport et euh
c'était vraiment difficile d'interférer, ils tirent
et c'est trop
difficile qu'ils ferment
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à demander à mon ami de demander à
espen de m'aider à me sauver
et de ne pas permettre aux talibans de  me tuer à
cause du trop grand nombre de vidéos et de la
vitesse que j'ai faites sur
les talibans et sur
tout ce que j'ai fait au basket et je travaille pour les
droits des femmes en afghanistan et ils peuvent être un
gros dossier pour les talibans me tuer ou
ma famille je pleurais juste j'ai pleuré
beaucoup pas parce qu'ils m'ont battu moi ou mon
mari juste au moment où j'ai dit à mon
mari de regarder
qui avait le contrôle de ce pays
dirigé vers notre maison
et j'ai enduré ils ont tué mon frère et
mon père a également enduré
et ils ont
changé ma vie pour toujours et à jamais
[Musique]
donc
toi